hello everybody and welcome to this
tutorial on yet a new opportunity to
come and work for the EU
institutions we have published a
competition to select specialists in the
field of nuclear energy very specific
and as usual on our landing page of the
competition we have published this
infographic which gives you an overview
uh of the five steps to take to become a
successful candidate and in this
tutorial I will walk you through these
different five
steps this competition has two Fields
field one is nuclear saf guards
inspectors and field two is policy
officers in nuclear energy and you see
the number of successful candidates
sought for both Fields here as an
applicant you can only apply for one of
these two
Fields the eligibility criteria it is a
very specific uh competition so it
requires very specific degrees and
professional EXP experience you either
need a master degree or a 4-year
University degree in a relevant field
plus six years of relevant experience if
you have just a bachelor degree you need
at least s years of relevant experience
if you do have a PhD in one of those
fields you just need to uh approve at
least two years of relevant experience
uh for this competition and if you have
a bachelor degree in any other field
than the ones relevant to this
competition you can also apply for the
first field nuclear safeguards
inspection but then you need to prove at
least 9 years of experience in the field
so you hear me say relevant a lot and
specific a lot so please do have a look
at the notice of competition where we
dedicate four pages to these relevancy
and these degrees and experiences that
uh are needed to be eligible for this
competition I'll give you some examples
for field one nuclear Safeguard
inspection uh the the degree must be
acquired in fields such as Nuclear
Physics nuclear chemistry radiation
protection
radiobiology engineering to name just a
few your professional experience must be
acquired in both an area and an activity
both criteria must be met areas such as
nuclear energies Eng engineering nuclear
safeguards nuclear physics R&D in small
modular reactors uh nuclear waste
management Fusion technology these are
all areas just to name a few that are
valid for this first field uh the
activity must be either in for instance
Safeguard inspections decommissioning
quality control R&D also a design of
reactors these things for the second
field the policy officers the degree can
be in any field it is not limited to a
set of
fields but then again if you have a PhD
it must be acquired in for instance
nuclear nuclear science chemical
engineering Material Science geology GE
geochemistry and some more the areas for
the professional experience for this
second field are refly the same as for
field one but the activity must be in
for instance developing policy because
we're looking for policy um experts it
can be in representation and liazon
scientific analysis legal work
operational activities project
management scientific research and so
forth so please do read the notice very
carefully because there it will tell you
which criteria are eligible for this
competition then of course there's
always a language Criterium you need to
master two different EU languages one of
which must be at minimum level C1 and
the second one at minimum level
B2 this is an unusual Criterium because
for the both fields we have a different
Criterium as you can see here in for
field one language one can be n of the
24 and language two must either be
English or French for field two language
one again is any of the 24 but language
two must be English so pay attention to
this um when
applying the selection procedure is the
common uh standard procedure as we know
it since uh 2023 actually since we have
started publishing competitions under
this new procedure model it all starts
with an application then there is of
course a testing phase where you see
three tests and after which you will be
uh uh communicated your results of this
um
tests very important to know is that the
testing happens in one single day and
all test test are being taken remotely
so you sit your Tre tests everybody who
applies sits the Tre tests you are not
notified of intermediate results of
these three tests you sit them all and
only at the very end you will be given
your
results important to know is that
recruitment of these people will mainly
be done in our offices in Luxembourg
some posts will also be uh vacant in our
jrc sites our joint research research
centers and we have six sites the
headquarters are based in Brussels and
then we have five sites in five
different countries being the
Netherlands Belgium Germany Italy and
Spain as you can see on this slide here
so let's have a closer look at these
different stages of the competition
everything starts with an application
for that you need an epso account if you
already have one you use that account to
apply if you don't you can simply create
one on our website you apply through our
website of course everything happens
online you will find the direct link to
this competition on the homepage you can
fill out your application in any of the
24 languages and you should validate
your application latest on the 21st of
November noon Brussels time so don't
miss that you can modify your
application until that date but you have
to validate it on the 21st of
November everybody who applies really
everybody who applies will be invited to
the testing
and as said we test or we make you sit
three tests and the first test is a test
to assess your reasoning skills we test
your verbal numerical and abstract
reasoning skills in language one so any
language but English or but even French
for the first field you see the number
of questions and the duration and the
scoring mentioned on this slide this is
a past fail test meaning that you need
to reach a certain part pass score being
10 out of 20 for verbal reasoning and
the combined pass score of 10 out of 20
for both numerical and abstract
reasoning
combined just meeting that pass score of
10 out of 20 is enough to still be in
the running for a place on the reserve
list whether you have 10 or more it's
all fine you just cannot fail so you
cannot have less than 10 out of
20 I strongly suggest you have a look at
our sample test page on our website
where you find examples of these
different reasoning skills tests in all
24 languages available and by having a
look at these questions you see the
level of difficulty that is um at stake
here you will also notice that there is
a Time factor involved you have to be
able to solve these questions under time
pressure and by training this you get
better at
this the second test uh is a field
related test where we test of course
your knowledge in the field of the the
competition you will see this test in
language two so English or French for
field one 30 questions in 40 minutes you
need to reach at least 15 out of 30 but
that will very probably not be enough
among the best ranked because indeed
this test uh will rank your uh scores so
and only the best scoring candidates
will eventually um get a place on the
list of successful
candidates the third test is a case
study you can see it in any of the 24
languages including English and French
it takes 45 minutes scored on 10 and you
need to reach the pass score of five out
of 10 again this is a past fail test so
just re uh reaching the minimum five out
of 10 is sufficient to be uh able to be
eligible if you want U to the list of
successful candidates through this case
study we test your written communication
your drafting skills we're not testing
knowledge in the field any longer it's
purely a test to assess your written
communication so the best ones uh
meaning the people with the highest
marks in the um Knowledge Test so the
the field related test and uh the people
who have
also reached the minimum pass Mark in
the case study and in the reasoning
skills tests those are the ones that
eventually end up on the list of
successful candidates or the so-called
Reserve list
and you see the numbers of people that
we uh are selecting again on this slide
these lists will be then handed over to
the institutions who will recruit from
this list whenever they have a vacancy
they will uh consult this list and look
at the CVS on the people of the people
on this list they will invite three four
five people to a job interview and the
best match will be offered the job at
stake the other people will stay on the
list and will be offered for another job
opportunity later in the year the
following months Whenever there is a new
vacancy
available if you still have questions as
I said please do read the noce of
competition very carefully because it
will answer most of your questions if
you still have doubts you can always
reach out to us through the web form on
our
website please do also follow us on
social media where you we keep you
updated on this competition and other
opportunities in the future good luck
with this application and good luck with
the tests bye-bye thank you for your
attention